j'ai pas le temps je me suis couché à 4
heures et 9 heures ça
9h42 voilà je me suis même pas rincer le
visage là là là c'est elle je sors du
lit comme ça je me dévoile sur youtube
c'est parce que j'ai pas le temps lettre
b voire fait vite fait j'ai pas le temps
ces formats je sors quand j'ai pas le
temps je n'ai pas le temps mais j'ai eu
le temps de trouver un sponsor pour
cette vidéo on perd pas le nord
je m'appelle cyrus mars ou pas un petit
et quand je parle de thé d'ailleurs
c'est le premier mot dont je vous
parlais
c'est le bateau de thé the eye les
blagues par contre ça ça ça arrive dès
le matin les mauvaises blagues je dirais
du coup on entend le son la bouilloire à
côté c'est peut-être pas la meilleure
chose mais c'est aussi ça ce format en
fait le bateau de taizé le bateau de
taizé c'est une expérience de pensée
attendait chelem un peu mal à l'aise
puisque ne suis pas mytho sur le visage
ça se règle à ce jeu mettre un petit
coup de jeu revient à masquer horrible
le bateau de taizé en gros c'est une
expérience de pensée
j'arrive cette expérience de pensée
c'est quoi c'est imaginons un bateau
donc celle celui de thésée personnages
issus de la mythologie grecque est en
fait c'est un bateau où on a remplacé
chaque partie du bateau mais
progressivement certains moments on
change le mât du bateau quelques temps
plus tard on change la barre quelques
temps plus tard on change le gouverneur
et puis on change le pont etc etc
la question qui se pose une fois qu'on a
changé tout le bateau progressivement
comme ça est ce que c'est le même bateau
en gros est ce que l'identité se fait
par la matière un changement de matières
implique-t-il un changement d'identité
la même chose pour nous d'ailleurs
toutes nos cellules elles changent tout
le temps en gros sur cinq à sept ans et
un renouvellement complet de toutes nos
cellules est-ce que je suis le même
du coup qu'il ya huit ans par iliad
thomas hobbes qui va encore plus loin
lui dans l'express de penser il dit ok
maintenant imaginons comprend toutes les
pièces détachées qu'on a remplacé en
fait genre l'ancien gouvernail
l'ancien marc etc etc avec ont construit
un autre bateau on va se retrouver que
deux bateaux c'est lequel le bateau de
thésée dans des lots les chaudes faut
que je me serve le thé sinon ça va être
froid alors il ya deux réponses
possibles à ça j'ai dit que c'était
sponsorisé cette vidéo mais j'ai payé
par qui elle est sponsorisée par horace
et je vous en parle juste après je vous
expliquer pourquoi le matin ça part dans
tous les sens c'est ce que je disais tak
tak regarde de manière de voir les
choses avec le bateau de thé ya la
manière un peu héraclite est en fait il
a une phrase ce que c'est une de mes
phrases préférées
ever je pense c'est l'homme ne se baigne
jamais deux fois dans une même rivière
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça parce que
tout change tout le temps tout change
tout le temps donc l'eau de la rivière
et changent tout le temps donc c'est pas
la même rivière en fait on peut pas se
payer deux fois dans un virage que je
rentre dedans je sors je vante c'est
plus la même eau donc c'est plus eux
mêmes les biens si on suit héraclite bas
le bateau these il change tout le temps
dans tous les cas donc non effectivement
c'est pas possible pas même bateau il ya
un autre point de vue par contre c'est
le père durand tisme eux ils ont trouvé
une petite faille
ils ont dit ok en fait un objet donc le
bateau these page dans un monde quadri
dimensionnelle ok c'est là les trois
dimensions plus le temps en amont quadri
dimensionnelle on peut dire que seul
bateau de taizé et donc qui perdure dans
le temps on peut le définir en 4d enfin
et 7,4 des ce serait une série de coupes
de 3d et donc ces éléments en 3d ce
serait un instant t faire qu'en fait le
bateau de thésée dans ce monde 4d serait
définie par une succession de bateaux
these de maintenant bateau de taizé de
maintenant bateau de taizé de même donc
les bateaux these de maintenant eux ils
changent et dans la définition de la
capter c'est à dire si on prend en
compte la valeur du temps c'est le même
bateau je vous ai même pas dit qu'elle
est et je me suis pris je me suis pris
un petit thé blanc voilà il ya un autre
bateau qui m'intéresse c'est le bateau
de ne rate
elle ne rate pas ce passage
le bateau de ne rate cette fois c'est
pas une expérience de pensée en rapport
avec l'identité mais c'est en rapport à
la connaissance ne rate il imagine
paraît un bateau en fait qu'on doit
réparer au fur et à mesure
progressivement mais on le fait pendant
qu'on navigue de sulfures on est en
pleine mer est en fait en pleine mer
pendant qu'on utilise le bateau il faut
continuer à le réparer comme ça ne rate
pour lui c'est un modèle de pensée de la
connaissance nous on va réévaluer des
éléments de sa connaissance
donc continuons d'apprendre des trucs et
se remettre en question et c'est mais ça
se fait progressivement et ça se fait
petit à petit par ajout par itérations
etc
cela s'oppose clairement à des cartes
pour qu'ils lui il faut tout détruire
pour bâtir une connaissance par dessus
et donc on comprend bien que par exemple
en économie en politique etc
on est clairement dans une sorte de
bateau ne rate on va pas détruire d'un
coup tout notre système économique ou
politique pour le changer ou alors si et
ça s'appelle une révolution puisque la
plupart des pays font depuis beaucoup de
temps c'est plus un bateau de marathon
on peut reconstruire entièrement le
bateau mais seulement progressivement
c'est bien deux autos me rate c'est un
philosophe autrichien dur m'amène g en
plein tournage d'une vidéo
du coup tu seras peut-être dedans ouais
les mecs tu vas être une star il m'a dit
on va être les nouveaux matelas carlito
je te rappelle d'appel vas-y ça je vous
en ferai une vidéo ce jeu j'ai pas le
temps mais j'ai le temps passé sur un
dôme phone il ya une vidéo qui est en
cours de préparation
alors petit déj ce fait ont juste un
truc
regardez moi ce cas-là diom c'est pas
magnifique ça c'est pas ouf c'est pas
trop beau
beauté on va parler de la beauté et
c'est le moment de vous parler du
sponsor de cette vidéo
horace horace ses marques de cosmétiques
française vers la vidéo j'ai pas le
temps vous savez un moment je fais ma
routine un peu ma routine beauté quoi
ils sont dix blazy non on va des
produits en fait j'ai discuté avec le
fondateur de la marque qui est hyper
cool la marque ces valeurs sont charmés
et où en gros les produits il son genre
trois à quatre fois moins chère que ce
que j'utilisais avant et ils sont mieux
en fait ils sont mieux parce que il ya
plein de trucs en fait qu'ils étaient
dans les ingrédients des produits que je
mettais genre par exemple il y avait un
truc fait nos exigences je sais plus
quoi c'est interdit par an pour les
peaux de bébés
je fais un bébé je pourrais en maître
pas ou quoi en plus les produits ils
sont faits en france et ce que j'aime
bien aussi c'est que dans leur cité est
une partie un peu magazines blogs etc
on n'aborde pas mal de questions qui
nous les mecs on se pose est un gros
effort aussi qui est fait en termes de
diversité
ce sont par ailleurs de la couleur de
peau mais aussi l'âge par exemple comme
le fondateur on le disait on n'est pas
tous david beckham est là bien raison et
complaintes regard ils font la peau en
général mais ils font aussi georges paba
rap dans cheveux je vais vous parler de
cheveux du goût pour les cheveux mois
c'est trop tard mais ça existe et donc
j'ai dit que j'allais vous parlez de
beauté tout en faisant ma routine à la
routine particulière aujourd'hui de
temps en temps je veux raza blanc
totalement
en mode manuel mousse à raser etc
j'essaie de le faire une fois par mois
parce que en fait quand je le fais pas
il ya des impuretés il ya des petits
endroits que je rate
quand je comme chez tout seul en fait
des trucs que je rate derrière ou sur
les côtés machin c'est pas parfait quoi
alors que quand je me rase vraiment haut
à avoir là tout y passe et même je
trouve ça bien pour la peau moi j'aime
bien ça me fait plaisir
donc on va faire ça à we dernier truc
pourquoi la peau c'est aussi important
pour moi bah en fait
bon déjà c'est l'été avant mais quand on
est chaud et notamment quand les choses
et on n'a pas de barbe la peau je n'ai
que ça en fait c'est le truc que vous
voyez le plus chez moi donc c'est
important de la nettoyer
c'est important de l'hydrater c'est
important d'en prendre soin et c'est ce
qu'on va faire ensemble
à ce moment vous étiez beaucoup à parler
de mardi noir une chaîne youtube
apparemment qui fait ça aussi
depuis longtemps elle fait son
maquillage et elle parle de philo
sociaux ou en tout cas laborde des
sujets intéressants
[Musique]
là la grosse question de la beauté c est
ce qu elle est universelle
d'abord en nettoie la peau ont l'art est
important et j'aime bien la réponse de
kant là dessus quand il dit la beauté
c'est ce qui plaît universellement sans
concept et c'est intéressant s'il ya
deux paradoxes l'a déjà ce qui plaît
universellement quand je dis un truc est
beau c'est un jugement de valeur
subjectif c'est moi qui le trouveront le
fondateur il m'a dit aussi que l'un des
trucs importants pour s'hydrater la peau
en fait le plus important au delà des
produits tous ces déboires de dh on peut
avancer sur l'hydratation de la peau
il ya une vidéo de syllabus qui est
sorti la semaine dernière qui est
incroyable tous les maires description
peut-être que vous demandez pourquoi
faut nettoyer sa peau transpiration
pollution etc tout ça s'arrête sur la
peau en fait je passe vous avez mis par
exemple sur un coton de l'eau micellaire
et vous avez déjà frotté votre peau
comme ça c'est fou la couleur c'est fou
j'espère que j'avais pack redonné 1
depuis le début de la vidéo
donc elle est bien nettoyer la peau pour
le rasage
j'ai des rasoirs jetables je les ai
depuis ch ça fait deux déménagements que
je me les trains bâle iii même j'ai
depuis trop longtemps donc je vais m'en
débarrasser faut je m'en débarrasse je
les aime pas du tout j'espère je perds
groupe est en fait j'ai la raser le gel
cela va comme ça on voit ce qu'on fait
autant le nettoyant j'ai déjà testé
génère également la gel à raser a
parfois on a dit pas quand tu dises
compte deux choses
ce qui me plaît parce que c'est agréable
jusqu'où plus ces raisons elles sont
nulles
quand il distingue de choses ce qui me
plaît parce que c'est agréable et ce qui
me plaît parce que c'est pourquoi un
saut de cheval agréable j'accepte la
subjectivité et j'accepte que les autres
trouvent cette même chose pas agréable
par contre quand ça me plaît parce que
c'est beau j'accepterai beaucoup moins
concert que tout le monde devrait
trouver ça beau mon jugement il est
subjectif mais il n'est pas relatif et à
une universalité dedans d'où le beau et
ce qui plaît universellement
j'aime bien le contact de la peau
j'adore la sam ea games
si quelqu'un de choses me dis j'aime pas
moins ok parce quelqu'un de chauffe ou
pas s'ouvrir le canadien homme me dit ah
je vous passez un bon mois cette plante
brad henry le deuxième paradoxe c'est ce
sens concept pourquoi dix ans concept il
dit sans concept parce que je ne peux
pas expliquer pourquoi je trouve quelque
chose de beau je vais donner des petites
raisons comme ça ex teint mais en vrai
ça s'explique pas
genre le canadien je vais dire t'as vu
toutes les couleurs sur les feuilles
hachées oui ok mais qu'est ce qui fait
que ces couleurs là tu trouve ça beau
qu'est ce qui fait que cette harmonie là
je trouve ça beau avec le succès que
s'il y avait un concept on analyserait
on décortique ray le beau et du coup
notre âme
il serait insensible donc même si il ya
de l'universel dedans y'a pas de concept
le beau et ce qui plaît universellement
sans concept le paradoxe du beau c'est
d'être à la fois singulier et universel
nouveau cyrus ans monsieur la beauté ça
fait penser à un autre truc kapalka losc
et gâteaux chez les grecs ça veut dire
beau et bon la personne qui était dit
beau et bon c'est vrai cette personne
qui avait atteint l'idéal d'harmonie
entre le corps et l'esprit quoi est
d'ailleurs anecdotes xénophon
l'historien et philosophe grec il était
compagnon de route de cyrus le jeune
donc sur le dow jones était le fils de
darius deux anecdotes d'ailleurs mon
père s'appelle vraiment darius pappas te
regarde cette vidéo je te fais un bisou
et il disait de cygnus le jeune qu'il
était beau et bon qu'à losc a tous voila
petite anecdote choix ça marrant bergson
henri bergson c'est un philosophe
français souvent on oublie que bergson
étaient français bergson sa peine tout
n'aurait été française il est des
français alors il a philosophé sur plein
de trucs mais un des trucs qu'on retient
beaucoup de personnes c'est sa pensée
sur la durée en fait il a opposé la
durée le temps scientifiques ils donnent
trois caractéristiques à la durée
d'abord la continuité la durée c'est un
énorme bloc l'indivisibilité ne pas le
sélectionner ce bloc là il n'est pas
mesurable comme on pourrait le faire
avec le temps scientifique et le
changement la durée n'est jamais
identique à elle même
contrairement au temps mesurables anton
mesurable dix minutes et dix minutes
mais comment je ressens c'est dix
minutes-là genre la durée qu'elle prend
chez moi dans mon intérieur ça change
toujours sait jamais la même chose en
fonction d'eux est ce que je suis
patient impatient j'ai des trucs à faire
après de bonne humeur de mauvaise humeur
donc la durée elle est vraiment dans la
vie intérieure et donc on peut dire
qu'il ya un dualisme berck sonia le
dualisme on l'a vu dans la précédente
vidéo j'ai pas le temps sur les lettres
à caen a parlé de l'âme effectivement là
quand on entend la définition de durée
pour personne il yad'un côté l'intérieur
l'esprit donc l'âme et de l'autre côté
l'extérieur la matière donc le corps un
autre élément important de la
philosophie de personnes en tout cas
j'espère c'est important le moi j'aime
bien ça m'apporte pour moi c'est le rire
il a fait il a fait tout un livre sur le
rire j'en ai fait une vidéo
c'était il ya quoi il ya deux ans
maintenant je pense juin leur
description mais en gros ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que le rire c'est un
système de défense de notre société
on rigole de quelque chose en fait qu'on
n'accepte pas trop dans la société
voyez par exemple parfois je parle avec
d'autres potes de lingerie masculine
eh ben il ya des potes qui se marrent et
pâteux vraiment si tu as des barques
quoi on ne sont pas ça drôle du tout je
sais pas ce qu'en fait certaines parties
de la société
quand je dis la société s majuscule loin
est ce minuscule ça dépend du contexte
ça peut être à l'échelle de la france où
ça peut être une mini société juste vous
avec vos amis et dans ce cas là en tout
cas quand mes potes rigole c'est que la
société n'a pas accepté la lingerie
masculine et donc s'est pointée du doigt
comme une défaillance quelque part et
donc le système de défense de la société
ça va être de dire c'est vrai de rigoler
en fait c'est un système de défense
hyper léger la des systèmes de défense
plus forts qui sont dire non ça c'est
pas ok mais le rire c'est un petit
système de défense c'est une manière de
faire comprendre à la personne tu es sur
le bord mon pote genre tu étais sur le
bord de ce conte de notre système
en fait c'est pas hyper bien expliquer
mais c'est beaucoup mieux expliqué dans
la vidéo pour ça d'ailleurs que l'humour
évolué vachement avec le temps parce que
les valeurs d'une société évolue avec le
temps au passage je crois que je vous ai
pas dit mais horace nous a filé un code
promo je les remercie parce que toutes
les marques ne le font pas en fait c'est
cool quand j'ai un code promo est ce que
je peux vous en faire profiter le code
promo c'est cyrus north et déjà que les
produits sont accessibles
vous avez en plus ou moins 20% alors si
vous avez la peau sèche comme moi moi je
vous conseille le kit visage d'un kit
visage dedans vous avez un nettoyant
donc le nez sans que j'ai utilisé un ex
polian ça le fait pas trop fait le max
une à deux fois par semaine
commencez par une fois par semaine voyez
comment vous la peau réagit
l'expérience est ce qu'il va vraiment
retirer toutes les peaux mortes et
ensuite une fois vous avez donc soit
utilisé nettoyant soit l'exfoliant quand
vous utilisez l'exfoliant vous utilisez
pas nettoyant sinon c'est trop ça va
être trop agressif pour votre peau après
vous utilisez la crème hydratante
moi j'aime bien faire matin et soir ok
là je vais faire la partie que les gens
aiment moins c'est
là bas j'ai un mois et demi de mêlée
sans les ans et quitte à moi j'aime bien
parfois shift ou totalement donc si là
j'avoue ça peut être pas mal pareil pour
les mêmes raisons j'aime bien que ma
peau et respire de temps en temps au
moins une fois par mois un vrai rasage
total je recommande pas ça j'y connais
rien je suis pas un expert de la peau
mais moi j'aime bien je sais pas si
c'est bien de le faire la transition
bien directement j'ai utilisé ce qui est
bien c'est ce qui répond à une attente
c'est ce qu'on approuve et donc ça
suppose l'existence d'une norme et du
coup il peut y avoir de très grosses
variations dans la définition de biens
selon les philosophes
j'ai trouvé un bouquin dans lequel y en
a quelques-unes et je vais vous le dire
pour platon par exemple le bien c'est
l'idéal dont le monde imparfait doit se
rapprocher pour aristote par exemple le
bien c'est le développement maximal pour
chaque être de sa nature propre pour les
épicuriens on vous l'aurez peut être
deviné le bien c'est le plaisir est donc
le bonheur pour les stoïciens le bien
c'est être en accord avec l'ordre
universel de la nature et donc le
bonheur pour quand le bien c'est la pure
intentions moral
on peut aussi le penser pour des
courants plus modernes par exemple
l'utilitarisme bat pour eux le bien ces
luttes il simplement
voilà ce qui est bien dépendant
vachement d'autres systèmes de pensée
quoi je trouve qu'on est pas mal là je
me suis coupé une fois voire deux au
tout début avec ces merdes
c'est un exploit jeu très content un an
trois frappeurs ça reste un exploit
l'appréciation il ya des mecs experts
carrière sa vidéo qu'ils isme moi même
avec ça je me coupe jamais tu sais pas
tu y prends un mec aussi main france je
suis dégoûté en fait c'était leur
dentifrice que j'ai mis ça c'est pas du
toit du dentifrice ont plus l albanais
vivant montré chaud donc là je margelle
après rasage alors là ça incroyable ce
qui se passe les cheveux c'est sûr côté
enfin je pense que je peux a besoin de
mettre 2
rémy des attentes après ça mais elle est
top je la recommande c'est pas un match
event quand même pour un youtuber de se
faire une routine comme ça sponsorisé
par une marque
est-ce que ça n'était pas la dernière
pierre hamon édifice de youtube heures
si jamais c'était ma dernière pierre
hamon et des fils de youtube heures
horace merci d'y avoir contribué chez
soleil en yo yo de son whisky
il nous reste un dernier mot le bonheur
bonheur le bonheur ça prend en compte
des éléments subjectifs
ok ce qui moi me rend heureux ça rend
pas heureux tout le monde
c'est la fameuse phrase le bonheur des
uns ne fait pas le bonheur des autres
n'est ce pas donc c'est ni universel ni
objectifs et saha répondent pas toujours
à une logique on pourrait dire que c'est
plutôt particulier subjectif et que ça
répond à des représentations mentales un
peu vague
et bien c'est pour ça que quand il a
cette phrase qui est assez puissante le
bonheur n'est pas un idéal de la raison
mais de l'imagination parce que si c'est
un idéal de la raison ce serait tout ce
que j'ai dit avant servent que ce serait
universel objectifs fixés mais non là
c'est un idéal de l'imagination
l'imagination c'est quelque chose qui
est très propre à nous qui est
particulier qui est subjectif et c'est
donc comme ce n'est pas un idéal de la
raison mais l'imagination
ça peut être un objectif de l'action
morale pour quand
et donc cette vidéo va se terminer sur
ce constat que je trouve magnifique qui
résulte de la démonstration que vient de
faire quand qui est qu' on ne devient
pas heureux en étant moral mais on
devient digne de l'être
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu je
remercie horace pour le soutient encore
une fois très belle marque très beaux
projets portés par des français fait en
france
de belles valeurs voilà on apprécie et
puis en plus c'est une marque qui je
trouve via leurs conduits dit orianne
extase sur leur site l aide
les hommes à se sentir mieux dans leur
peau donc ça me fait plaisir de soutenir
les marques comme ça tout simplement moi
je voulais c'est je vais remporter sept
monstres à doumbia qui s'est acclimaté à
l'humilité de mon appartement je pense
que là il est temps de la rempoter
maintenant et j'ai plein d'autres trucs
à faire je vous prépare plein de choses
voilà j'espère que ce format vous plaît
toujours autant le premier il va
vraiment plus donc ça fait plaisir
et la semaine prochaine on se retrouve
pour est ce que vous êtes des merdes et
cette fois ça va être vos histoires love
peace ciao j'ai pas trop